uh uh yeah okay so all the audio levels
should be better on this freestyle flow
yeah everything should be more balanced
yo the audio from YouTube Studios
beautiful this is called the Creator
music beta yeah we got it filtered by
hip hop and pop and it's all free to use
[__] yeah that is so dope and then we
got my audio level on this wireless mic
should be all balanced up should sound
nice and better than the first round
freestyle that we just did let's see how
this goes where is this going to go
nobody knows yeah you know that's the
truth you're the entire universe you
[__] fool don't even try to
[__] hide you can't [__]
hide the nothing inside everything
everywhere at once yeah you know it's
true yeah you know it's true it's all
conditional love you fool yeah it's all
Freedom appearing as this yeah [__] yeah
absolute freedom appearing as this
Soundtrack This freestyle entering the
ears out of the mouth into the ears of
absolute freedom without a Center Point
anywhere in sight you bloke just cuz
there's a body doesn't mean there's a me
or a center point it's just bodies
everywhere one
Universe
functionality of the body is basic needs
yeah get that water that food that
housing that energy yeah decentralize
those basic needs all of a sudden
there's no matri tricks mentality of the
bodies everybody is just free it's just
free to play every day in the sly with
its friends doing whatever it wants
absolute freedom absolute freedom
already this already this already this
uh ooh this one was pretty
good so we're on the third page of this
there's many so looks
[Music]
like could probably keep doing this for
a while all these different freestyles
with these instrumental
tracks and just see where it keeps going
and flowing huh
yeah just want to double check the usage
details of the ones that are
[Music]
good okay we could play with this
one yeah cuz up here I saw that this
usage detail required
[Music]
a including the following information in
the description that's just more of a
[Music]
headache
okay uh yeah that puppy dog Emoji in the
live chat yeah you know that's how we do
puppy dogging
ah innocence woof woof woof woof that
innocence woof woof that innocence woof
woof that innocence yeah you already
know it's always been that innocence
it's always been that innocence it's
never left that
innocence yeah even that illusion of a
sense of me is that same in a sense
can't you see pretty [__] easy yeah
you know it's right we can do this all
night these freestyle flight fly
[__] fly Unbound every single
box every single bound is Just an
Illusion there is no bounds there are no
boxes everything is you every single
continent every single planet in the
[__] universe is you it's all your
godamn body you fool just wake up to the
spiration porn that's where all the
attention [__] goes that's where it
flows because that's the biggest
deception yo the [__]
Cornerstone of ignorance yo is that
separation pouring dropping bombs on
yourself on your arms on your legs on
your toes on your face because of
differing
beliefs yeah I'm at one with God and
you're you're not so I can shoot your
face with a [__] Glock yeah you
know that's what all these [__]
talking about yeah you know these
[__] they about trying to get more
for themselves and less for the hole
because the hole isn't them yeah [__]
ignorance ha that's how the game of the
innocent Universe goes and [__] himself
up with the center points with the
illusion of a separate me that needs to
get more and more money more and more
material more and more things because I
lack and I need all these things so [__]
the whole that's how it thinks it
doesn't even care if it's at the brink
of an entire civilizational collapse it
don't give a [__] because all it cares
about is its own ass that tight butthole
yeah you know same thing with the
sphincter on the eye that's called the
iris contracted in its dilation
is yeah you know that's how it sees like
a [__]
blinders tunnel
vision yeah of course that's how it
works of course that's how it works how
else could it work Universe Contracting
down into a little tiny thing oh my God
I lack I real I exist I'm my
[__] name you are others you
are [__] lame I want to take
everything from you more and more for
myself maybe then I'll finally feel
fulfilled you're already fulfilled
[__] you're already the whole
you are already not an entity you bloke
you're already everything everywhere at
once pretty [__]
easy uh good track good track I like
this one let's see what's
next question in the chat about if I am
sober answer is yes of
course bro in one video you mentioned
that there is no self but after you say
you are ever everything everything is
you yeah of course
obviously it's the same
[Music]
thing what is
this uh what's this
one okay okay we can jam with
this we can jam with this okay
okay all
right all
right see all of these [__] questions
about no self or being everything are
the same goddamn thing it's all the same
thing there is emptiness inside
everything is wholeness there is no
individual in sight it's to
[__] easy can't you see there
is only the wholeness all of nature just
like the trees everything is one
organism there is no separation boxes or
[__] bounds everything is the same
nameless goddamn flow everything is that
one thing without a center yo it's too
[__] easy but you try to make
it complicated with all these Concepts
and ideas put a stop to it it's that
[__] easy just cease all that goddamn
[__] it's too [__] easy yeah
[__] love you in the
[__] live chat ho yeah you
[__] know and all these conversations
about is this sober or is this on some
substance oh yeah that makes such a big
difference if this is tripping on a
psychedelic or a substance like cannabis
or alcohol or tobacco because all that
mind knows how to do is conceptualize
because it's a [__] fool it
wants to put everything into boxes
nonstop it wants to demonize certain
substances versus not that's all it
knows how to do you are a fool if you
don't agree with my ideas you yeah and
then that's the start of war I'm smarter
than you I know more than you so you are
dehumanized I can kill you it's that
[__] simple this is chaos it's
Anarchy everything goes it's a
decentralized autonomous organization yo
yeah it's all [__]
entertainment and comedy for
[__] nothing it's that simple
yo comedy and entertainment for nothing
appearing as
this simple quite simple yo quite quite
simple yo nothing complicated it's all
ordinary and simple Just Like the Wind
wrestling through the
[Music]
trees no concrete no solidity yeah you
know that's key because concrete
solidity be an illusion it be a mirage I
think I'm my name yeah right yeah oh I'm
my name I'm a Center Point you're other
and that's the positioning game that's
being played where it doesn't even exist
yeah now rub your tits yeah rub those
nipples and be free rub those nipples
and [__] be free rub the nips
rub the nips free the nips free the nips
free the nips
yeah free the nipple free the nipple
free the nipple free the
nipple uh uh uh free free free the
[__] nipple yeah free the nip
free the nip free the ball sack I'm not
wearing underwear yeah I'm all that and
same with you no underwear ooh free ball
free [__] free vag free dick free [__]
free everything free everything free
everything just like that innocent baby
or or that dog or that cat where are the
[__] clothes can't find them then
there's that story of Adam and Eve oh my
God I know now so I got to put these
clothes on and I will put my mask on
because I shame oh my God I'm so worried
now about everything because of
Separation that doesn't even [__]
exist Cosmic
joke
that's a fun
one let's see this
one okay yeah we can play with this
[Music]
one some more comments let's
see looks like there's some gaming
happening
and then there's playing this listening
to this while Gaming's
[Music]
happening no actually there's a question
in the chat about if it's a big trip
being everything actually the biggest
trip is being a center point the biggest
trip is that you're a sense of me that
is separate from the hole that you're
not everything everywhere at once and
the emptier you are the more obvious it
is more obvious it
[Music]
is
yeah
we yeah see everything's okay
everything's okay everything goes
everything goes everything flows
everything goes everything flows no
separation in sight everything's okay
hey just take flight whatever is meant
going to happen just whatever is going
to happen it's already the infinite
Cosmic flow there's not even ability to
surrender yo because it's already the
very thing that's happening everywhere
at once yeah the whole thing is
[__] you there is only the
[__] ocean you fool but it doesn't
even matter these are empty words
everything that's being said is empty
words
and the thing that's listening is empty
it doesn't even matter nothing even
[__] matters and that's the freedom
that is even sought the fact that
everything's already absolutely free
everything is already absolutely free
this is not a journey or a destination
there's no entity there's no location
it's already free it's already free it's
already free just a movie playing just a
movie playing whatever's AR Rising on
the screen of perception whatever's
happening whatever sensation thought
idea whatever doesn't matter it's all
just empty
[Music]
flow okay we can go with this for a bit
let's see what happens let's see what
happens yeah live chat be free as
[__] live chat be free as [__] absolute
letting go of
everything yeah there's no entity to
grab or let go because there's already
no one home never ever been anyone home
never ever been anyone home it's already
been Perfection already no one home
already no one home already free already
free already free already
free already only the
whole already only the
whole may as well have the body
functionality go to serve the hole cuz
there's only the hole only the hole only
the hole only the hole only the hole
it's so obvious just look down at the
Earth from the sky and see there's only
one thing happening here it's you it's
just empty flow that's you it's
everywhere at once there's no center
point it's everything happening at once
it's [__] love it's Freedom
it's Perfection everything is this
simply this just this whatever's
appearing is freedom anything appearing
is freedom and wholeness everything
appearing is wholeness everything
appearing is wholeness it's all innocent
free and spontaneous it's all innocent
free and spontaneous what up
yeah un holess was such an illusion h
[Music]
what is
this
okay okay
okay uh uh uh
uh
yeah uh yeah okay there's a question in
live chat about liking Douglas Harding
yeah yeah headless way headless way
headless way no one home anyway too
[__] simple and easy the thing that
looks out your eyes is nothing
everything it's too [__] easy
[__] no one home is the riddle
of the universe too [__] easy too
[__] easy often overlooked and then
everything else wants to be grabbed and
be attained because it feels unhold
trying to fill the void inside it can't
be filled it can never be filled all you
can do is just [__] be it just
[__] be the void that's already
there it's already everywhere it's too
[__] easy [__] fool
it's too easy oh my God I lack therefore
I need I will grab everything in sight
to try to fill up what's empty inside it
will never ever ever ever happen
[__] it will never happen
because it's already here it's already
there it's everywhere wholeness is
already
everywhere the very thing that's hearing
these words is emptiness the very thing
that's watching this video is already
whole it's already empty it's already
fulfilled can't you see to [__] easy
too [__] easy too [__] easy really
it's too [__] easy then it's over
complicated with all these Concepts and
ideas and all this knowing oh my God I'm
on a pedestal because I know and you
don't haha that's Duality [__]
is not
true
[Music]
okay
uh okay okay
yeah uh yeah much love in the fam
chat
yeah freedom is already here freedom is
already here freedom is already here
because there isn't even an entity it's
already free it's already free there's
no entity it's already free already free
no
entity already free already free no
entity only the whole only the whole haa
all this shit's way too funny man
there's only the whole yet there is this
illusion of a center point and then it
goes [__] crazy it's killing other
people no problem because it doesn't
care it thinks it's others there's no
such thing as another there's never been
a [__] other it's not possible for
there to be separation or another ha haa
haa
[Music]
BL
BL blah blah empty Concepts empty
Concepts everything is free everything
is already free everything is already
free already free already free already
free already free already
free already free already free empty
king can't you see already free already
free yeah wholeness can't you see
wholeness can't you see it's already
free Everything at Once everywhere at
once
yeah everywhere at once everywhere at
[Music]
yeah Hess is so fulfilling yes it
is and it's already here there's nothing
to it everything is so wow it's so
beautiful profound it's so pure it's so
joyful and Blissful and
cool
already and
forever enjoy it enjoy it just a
firework show for No One enjoy it enjoy
it just a firework show for no one for
No One firework show for no one
yeah firework show for no one already
free already free already free already
free simply basic
[Music]
needs
okay we can do
this All right what we got in the live
chat oh
uh yeah yeah there's more questions
about psychedelics yeah man you sure you
not dropping acid bro see this this is
the fascinating thing this is the
natural state it's already this this is
already what is it's already what is
before any contracted Center Point that
then needs to take
substances the contracted Center Point
the me that is the psychedelic
trip the most psychedelic thing in the
universe is that their separation isn't
that crazy and then it needs to take
apparent psychedelics to realize it's
everything so the natural state is that
there's no
one it's actually the least psychedelic
the least trippy thing imaginable is
that you're everything everywhere at
once because you're no one you are
everyone everything so simple
man too simple too free too simple too
free too simple and free and then the me
wants to over complicate with Concepts
ideas boxes and Bounds separation yeah
and then it leads to war leads to
ideologies yeah that shit's crazy
[__] it's Perfection or Rising
as the craziest [__]
imaginable absolute mindblowing the
illusion of a center point I am a
separate something I don't like these
other separate some things I want more
for myself because I believe I am real
and separate and profound I am so
special with my knowing and that
ignorant fool is an absolute chump and I
have no problem blowing their head
off that's the sound of
ignorance but it's still
perfect it's still the freedom of
everything believing in separation a
complete
illusion yes it
is complete
[Music]
illusion separation is a complete
illusion a center point is an
illusion an entity is an
illusion pull that thread all the way to
non
loal
[Music]
freedom
I don't know if I get handal this
sophomore make
out oh all right what's
[Music]
this okay we'll play with
it
[Music]
uh okay yeah oh nice yeah I like that
comment okay so there's a comment in the
live chat about how much time and energy
is wasted on ego energy yeah yeah that's
extremely [__] true even though it's
Perfection already freedom no one
arising as that it's still [__] un
energy suck yes it is I am unho so I
need so then I manipulate everything in
the appearance to try to fill that void
and then I don't care at all about the
whole I forget about basic needs I
forget about solar Punk future free
energy I forget about new
communities I forget about
decentralization I forget about
abandoning separation I forget about all
of those things and so I'm excessively
focused on me so then all of my energy
goes to me how can I get more material
possessions I lack I lack I lack I need
more more more more more six figures
isn't enough I need seven or eight just
to feel worthy and be validated by my
parents and society and then I can get a
proper girlfriend friend and then I can
have a family you see if more and more
people run that same script this whole
place is going to mutually assur
destruction or M A yeah that spells mad
[__] the opposite of mad is D
Dao decentralized autonomous
organization of basic needs Prosperity
because the self sees its empty when the
self sees its empty it is no one that
sees the emptiness that that it is
therefore the functionality changes from
the script of lack to the script of
wholeness imagine
[Music]
that H
interesting it doesn't look like this
one's an instrumental
[Music]
but
wait go back to this one there we
go okay let's see where this one takes
us so some of these that are not
instrumentals seem also pretty
good let's go okay let's
go uh uh uh uh uh yeah okay question in
the LA chat yeah there is no time yeah
there is no space yeah there is nothing
appearing nothing appearing nothing
appearing yeah can't understand it can't
know it can't know it obsolete the
question abandon the question can't know
it no one to know it no one to know it
obviously nothing everything
in an appearance called time and space
so just abandon the question [__] that
question you are literally Divine
Perfection asking a question you are
already empty asking a question about
what is
this
obviously it's nothing everything it's
nothing everything it's nothing
everything nobody knows that there's no
hierarchies of knowing there's no
hierarchies of knowing it's all already
empty and fulfilled empty empty and
fulfilled empty empty and fulfilled
Divine Perfection is listening to this
is speaking these words no one to hear
no one to say it just a bunch of water
flowing just a bunch of air flowing just
a bunch of wind moving who gives a [__]
it's already [__] free it's already
[__] free there's nowhere to go it's
already [__]
free it's already [__] free it's
already absolutely free and perfect
already that there's no entity already
you never came you will never go there
is no one that comes and no one that
goes It's Already Free it's already free
no entity ever came or goes ever ever
came or goes no entity ever came whever
goes ever came whever goes ever came
whever goes it's so simple and ordinary
just like the wind just like the air the
water All Is One Thing Called Love
called Freedom called unconditional
Perfection no one everyone nothing
everything it's one not
two that's a fun one
huh all
[Music]
right
ha cute
comments
H well played
haha total healing
aloneness everythingness nothingness yes
uh good morning sunshine back
fam good
evening
uh wherever
whoever it's all that same nothingness
inside
everything
yeah just kick back relax nothing to do
everything is perfection only a fool
would ever run around like a chicken
with its head cut off trying to get
wholeness when it's already that already
that already that already empty and free
already empty and free never left it
can't possibly leave what's already free
it's already free it's already so
[__] free it's already so Divine
can't you see it's everything everywhere
at once Divine Perfection appearing as
everything everything is wow Perfection
everything is awe everything is beauty
it's an explosion of colors and lights
like a movie like fir works it's divine
Perfection
already nothing has to
happen yet the body
functionality stops being about itself
and it starts serving the whole serving
the whole through basic needs abundance
for all innocent play childlike
free that was fun
too
ooh ooh uh
ooh uh holy [__] uh uh okay holy [__]
let's
go there's a comment in the live chat
about
[Music]
how about how it used to
take psyched to feel like
this and the beautiful thing is when
that Center Point is dissolved and that
Center Point is seen through it is seen
that it never was it never was and then
the natural state is the
whole the same thing that was felt
through psychedelics becomes natural
becomes natural it's the whole it's
always been here psychedelics were
simply dissolving the construct of me
that center point of lacking and needing
everything thing it's all that it's all
that it's always been that emptiness
having an experience of the center point
that lacks and needs it turns into the
center of the
universe yeah so when that nonsense is
seen through it's seen through by
nothing that it's everything you yeah
beautiful huh
yeah impossible to have ever left
[Music]
you know what I'm going to go one more
play on this and then we'll go to the
next one this one was
[Music]
fun h
huh you know there's nothing to say fam
not a single word can't [__] touch
this the ineffable music that's this the
words the listening is already freedom
and Perfection yeah yeah you can already
sense it it's already that Divine
unspeakable Perfection nothing has to
happen nothing nothing has to happen
it's already free it's already perfect I
know you already see that
[Music]
yeah how free how free nothing how free
how free everything yeah it's that
simple everything that's appearing is
[__] free everything that's appearing
is free everything that's appearing is
perfect and free perfect and free
perfect and free perfect and free yeah
[Music]
uhoh ooh uh
all right let's see where this one takes
us
[Music]
I love how the live chats vibing with
each
other those love
Vibes ooh okay okay maybe we'll reveal
some nipple action again yeah freedom
freedom freedom freedom freedom freedom
freedom
freedom freedom freedom let's get a
little closer to that nipple
yeah nipple nipple
nipple nipple nipple
action yeah nipple nipple
[Music]
action booty booty
action uh might have to start and only
fans and charge nothing for it and just
reveal the clip ha reveal the dick
reveal all the
genitalia open up like that baby doger
cat no clothes on that you already know
that is innocence imp Purity no shame no
self inside doesn't give a [__]
[__] just pure SP spontaneous
nakedness yeah uh uh uh uh
[Music]
uh now we're going to thrust we're going
to thrust and thrust get that sexual
that reproductive force and work yeah
making more baby
uh never comes or goes always
nothingness appearing as apparently more
bodies more
bodies never separation never never
separation even though there is an
illusion called a nation yeah you know
that's an illusion all those Border
Lines it's an imaginary box where
there's none yeah and you know that
perfectly serves this something that's
everything feeling
separate what a fun
[Music]
game okay
all right let's
[Music]
play
uh uh a sweet this some real
freestyle going to get Shadow banned
that's funny that's cute yeah yeah
that's why we only go nip that's why we
just go nip uh uh little booty Shake uh
yeah yeah maybe a little thrust uh uh
yeah uh yeah you know it's already whole
already free yeah nowhere to go no one
to be already whole already free nowhere
to go no one to be yeah you know it yeah
you know it simple as that yeah you know
it already whole already free nowhere to
go no one to be yeah and then we just
Shepherd basic needs on Earth abundance
for everyone in a sense gets to play
wake up every day and how do we want to
play because basic needs are met nothing
else needs to be done so we play so we
play every day
innocent children at play like we were
before all these dumbass
ideas entered into the body and
contracted the energy into me I lack an
I need I am separate from the I need
more and more until I destroy the Earth
because I don't give a [__] because I
can drop the bombs because I believe
that my people are smarter than yours
because my people are better my my
people are better so I will
dehumanize you and drop those bombs on
your shelters I don't give a [__] I want
more for me less for you separation porn
yeah that's what everything does it
contracts into that separation porn it's
hilarious more and more people on social
media watching eating popcorn a
separation
[Music]
porn oh
interesting
okay okay
okay uh okay we can play we can play
uh
okay let's pick up where we left off
with that separation porn social media
accounts just a door eating popcorn over
over again laughing at the battles that
are apparently happening in that
separation porn ha isn't this appearance
of the cosmic joke
hilarious yeah oh oh I will just watch
on social media yo yeah and laugh at
[Music]
that meanwhile
meia just promulgates the fear yeah drop
that
tear but it is what it is it's all
Divine perfection swimming in it the
whole thing is you the whole thing is
you yeah no
separation
yeah
[Music]
okay
wow so free it can appear as all of
this so free it can appear as all of
this yeah even
the no separation can appear as
separation how crazy is that
yeah
[Music]
you M
freedom freedom that always was always
is yeah always
[Music]
is
infinite love
fam wish we could see some nips shared
back
uh uh free the nip
fam free the nip
[Music]
fam free the nip fam free the nip
fam
[Music]
all right probably do let's see if we
get a couple more
[Music]
in what do we got
here okay
okay
[Music]
okay H yeah and then we'll probably be
on again later tonight who knows what
genre of stream will have fun
exploring zoomi zoom
zoom yeah zoomi zoom
[Music]
zoom
M
yeah got to love all these different
genres yeah of streams we got the
freestyle streams like this yeah that's
dope huh super damn fun
uh then we got the mukbangs the ones
with the notes the ones with all the
different topics to
explore yeah then we got
the
uh episodes on a single topic which are
fun or the guest interviews those are
also fun man we got so many varieties
with these streams we even got ones with
nonsense those are super fun though blah
blah blah blah blah blah nobody can
understand what's being said wolf woof
wolf meow meow meow oink oink oink oink
absolute nonsense and
[Music]
noise that's another genre of stream
super fun yeah ASMR another genra of
stream super fun yeah that's soft
voice yeah probably get some more of
those
yeah give some long
form fun
playful pointing to the true nature
which is literally everything that's
even said everything that's heard is it
there is no moving away from true nature
it's already here and already
free
[Music]
let's see let's see
here so much fun to Freestyle and stream
free Frey style and stream no straight
jacket on me no straight jacket on you
just absolute freedom non local and
free nameless and
free just Dowing basic needs Dowing
Dowing basic needs abundance and play
for all is the key to life so simple so
simple all there is is already the whole
there's no separation no separation
there's not even Nations just the lucer
bounds and
[Music]
borders yeah uh Freedom uh uh uh uh uh
Freedom
okay yeah what I'll do at the end is I
will wrap with one of my favorite
instruments it's simply a little cross
ball
and what you do is you take it put it up
against the wall like this and then you
just get into the muscle like this and
just roll it on those glutes glutes are
one of my favorite places to roll a la
la lacrosse ball yeah and then you can
go up to the lats and
trapezoids ah just drop it right behind
that shoulder blade and then lean back
in massage open up all those
contractions in the body yeah be free
yeah be free yeah be free be free open
up all those contractions in the body
and be free and be free open up all
those contractions in the body and and
be free
yeah feel so
good I'll probably do more of these fun
physical
fitness streaming too yeah
uh all different kinds of streams
yeah freedom freedom freedom of out to
wrap the stream up freedom
[Music]
freedom thanks for tuning in family
family thanks for tuning in basic needs
for
all
beautiful
okay all
right thanks for tuning
in much love those comments about
painting in the streams yeah these uh
cameras do a great functionality where
you can see what I'm like writing and
stuff we might do some of that
too
yeah be
fun
yum
okay all right well probably see you uh
later do another stream of sworts so
much
love wholeness always basic needs
always unconditional love always Freedom
always